whooping join the cruise I was left at
the altar a few days ago and my dad who
I haven't seen since I was 5 showed up
to my wedding
unannounced the two of us got incredibly
drunk that night and I must have blacked
out because
hi sweetheart oh [ __ ] somehow I dragged
him onto this cruise that was supposed
to be my honeymoon
you're in the honeymoon suite
congratulation oh that's my dad I'll be
back in the office on Thursday I'm
leaving early because I don't need a
vacation Rachel
earth to Rachel Rachel how are you fine
[Music]
are you gonna go on pretending you're
still fine with what happened the other
day she hates me frankly I can't blame
her I've been a therapist now for four
months so I want to give you my
professional opinion for free it's all
your fault
thank you
I did not want to end up alone
fear of loneliness is a very powerful
thing
[Music]
we were better without me there
[Music]
why are you here after all this time why
now
retain richly racial Harry you're insane
thank you
yeah okay - yeah good hang
[Music]
you